(gentle music)
- I'm standing in the MoMA stores
and I want to talk today about a poster
of 1912 to 13 designed
by the German designer
Ludwig Hohlwein for Kaffee Hag.
Kaffee Hag was one of
a number of foodstuffs
that represent German innovation
in applying scientific principles
to new foodstuffs.
It was a decaffeinated kind of coffee,
which was advertised at this time
as being healthy,
and hence, Hohlwein's decision
to link it to this man
clad in his tennis whites.
By 1913, Kaffee Hag
already had a strong visual
and brand identity on the market.
It was just succinctly
referenced in this image.
You can see half of the icon appearing
on the side of the coffee mug,
but that was enough to trigger
recognition of a brand.
The strength of the image really relies
on this very simple,
incredibly economical visual means
to communicate the message
with bold use of forms
and contrasted tonalities,
a limited color palette
and a very modern approach
to the typography,
using this Sans Serif type.
And what was unusual
and new and very modern
for the time was his
use of negative space.
You really are focused
on the title Kaffee Hag.
Another example of this
wonderful economy of means
and giving the image a
slightly humorous touch
is the way he's accommodated
the printer's name
in the shape of a tennis ball.
And it's not only about
branding of the product,
it's also about the
branding of Ludwig Hohlwein
as a graphic designer.
By 1925, he'd designed about 3,000
of these posters.
His signature is located
in the bottom
where he's extended the
umlaut over Munchen, Munich,
to connect to his name in this compact
and graphic rendering of his identity.
(gentle music)